all right so that's my introduction now
i want you to have a look at this
question here now this was in
your um this was in the handout that we
uploaded to canvas back on tuesday so
maybe you've had a go at this question
already but i'm not going to assume all
of you have
so at this point i'm going to give you a
few minutes to have a think using the
knowledge that we just kind of unpacked
um over the last five minutes you've got
this situation here
where you have this body and it's sort
of here in the center and
we can call that the origin it's being
acted on by the four forces f1 f2
and f3 and it tells you the magnitudes
of each of those as well
um this one's one two four and five
what will be the resultant motion of the
body what what direction will the forces
be pushing it in
okay now one of the options is in
equilibrium and they kind of look like
it's like sort of a star shape it looks
pretty close right however you know
from the outset even just by looking at
this diagram i hope you can see
this diagram is not going to be as
useful as you'd hope because it's not to
scale
and so the argument that we made looking
at all these previous diagrams doesn't
hold
how can i prove that very very quickly
just have a look at this distance here
this one here which is apparently meant
to represent
1. when i compare that to f4
which is this distance over here
i don't know how long f4 is but it does
not look 5 times longer
than f1 so you know that this diagram is
not to scale even though they don't tell
you
that it's not to scale so what i'm going
to do now is ask you if you haven't
already
or even if you did this question already
and grab a ruler out please use a ruler
it's going to be immensely helpful to
you
and have a go at drawing this diagram
it's 805 on my clock so i'm going to
give you a couple of minutes
to have a go at this you guys have an
added advantage which you've got grid
paper i know i could turn on grid paper
but i'm deliberately not using it
because in the hsc you will not get grid
paper so you have to be able to
again definitely use your ruler to try
and get some sense of scale here and
help yourself out
i'm going to give you yeah that time to
draw a diagram for yourself
and then i'm going to reveal to you what
my diagram looks like and how i reason
my way through it
so let me pause if you've got questions
you're welcome to pop them into the chat
because mrs lees and i can see that
and otherwise i will hold for a minute
while you draw your own diagram and
please take the time to draw a good one
you'll desperately need it
okay so i hope that's given you enough
time to have a think
we're going to build this diagram and as
i mentioned before you can do these
vectors in any order
but um i mean why not do them in the
order that's presented one two three
and then four so here's where i'm going
to begin
you can see i've drawn in f1 just starts
from the origin and then up it goes
and f2 is heading off again in a
northeast ish
direction it would be northeast if this
angle here was 45 degrees
but it's not it's 60. so what i've done
is
i've drawn this in here now i'm just
going to pause before i go any further
you can see i um i don't have a ruler
here on me but i i used one actually
when i was drawing this
however even though we don't get a grid
when we um
when we're in the final hsc um i am
going to show you there's a
sort of um neat trick that you can use
it's not really a trick it's just
thinking about trigonometry and its
relationships really
that will help you draw this diagram to
scale
when you have a look at this right i've
got this angle 60 degrees off of here
and so what i can think about is the
fact that
there's triangles everywhere kind of
hidden in this diagram i'm trying not to
do
too many extra lines because they're
going to cloud our diagram quite badly
but i want you to see this particular
line up here let me just move this out
of the way
that i haven't constructed yet and i'm
going to put it in in green over here
all right now have a look carefully at
this uh new triangle that we formed here
because i have drawn the lines um the
dotted lines that form the sides of this
triangle at right angles right
i've got this right angle triangle in
here and then i also have this um
60 degrees right now this therefore for
the with the 60 and the 90 means that
this is the 30 60 90 triangle this is
not a random triangle
you're going to see 60 degrees coming up
an awful lot
um for the same reason that you saw you
know root threes appearing when we were
doing complex numbers
because it just makes the manipulation
of arithmetic and the geometry much
easier to handle
we're not trying to make this awkward
for you to provide you terrible angles
that make things just
a pain to try and manipulate we want you
to focus on the geometry and the the
reasoning through this
not the fact that the the numbers are
awkward right so the fact that i've
created the 30 60 90 triangle here
and the fact that the 2 is on the
hypotenuse maybe you can see that if
this is 30
and sine 30 is a half right then
opposite on hypotenuse
gives you one on two this is the one two
root three triangle
so as a result i know that this is one
and that tells me you can see how i've
actually used the scale
even provided by my horizontal lines
here if this is one
i've used two lines to indicate that
rather than one so that my diagram isn't
microscopic
if this is one then this also has to be
one so you can see it vertically going
up by that same amount
and that should mean this is roughly
root three so if you were using well not
roughly root three should be exactly
root three but if you were using like
your
um uh your ruler to measure this out
right you would think ah that should be
one point seven
ish centimeters or three point four if
you're going double or whatever scale
that you like
so that's me trying to do this diagram
in a sensible way
so i've got the 3690 there and that's f2
that's really good
going back up you can see i've got f3
here it's going 120 degrees off
clockwise from the vertical but also
notice that its magnitude is four
right so when i construct this right i
want you to think about this carefully
if its angle is 120 degrees
clockwise from the vertical and it's
magnitude is 4 which is
double this can you see there's going to
be some relationships here right
for example you can see if i just go
half way like so because you've got this
120 degrees here do you notice that
going backwards to f2 right that's also
120 degrees going this way because
you've got co-interior angles
formed between this this vertical here
on the left and this vertical here on
the right so 120 degrees
versus 60 degrees because they're
supplementary so this 120 degrees on the
left hand side of the diagram let me
just highlight that in orange so you can
see it sort of
in comparison it's going to be
symmetrical to this 120 degrees
on the right hand side so i'm going off
in the same direction there i go
two units and in order to get to the end
of f3
i just have to go twice as fast so you
can see there's f3
over there and i've got this kind of
half way point here
right where this is 2 and this is also 2
and that gives me
4. now this is super important because
you can see
remember how i mentioned this is one
unit here well this is one unit
as well in fact i'm even going to show
that one unit
like so there's one unit so now i'm in
line
and then i get one unit again because
i've got the same i've got
i'm congruent triangles happening here
right so i've got this
relationship over here i don't know why
i drew that so wonky
there's that same horizontal length that
we saw up here which is root three
and then we see it one more time over
oopsy daisy
over here okay
so i wonder if you're piecing together
how we're going to be able to finish
this right
i've got this root 3 up here because of
this 30 60 90 triangle
and that same root 3 appears again and
again as after i've done f1 and then f2
and then f3
and now i have my final question or my
final vector rather to answer the
question
which is after f1 and f2 and f3 what
happens when i apply a 4.
now because i know the magnitude of this
vector f4 right
the the final part of this question i
know that i'm not
going to be moving north i'm not going
to be moving
in the direction 30 degrees south of
west
south of west that's kind of off in that
direction because you can see
i'm in line right now i'm kind of on
this horizontal
line here the east-west line or the
east-west axis if you like from the
origin
so i'm not going to have any up or down
because f4 is not going to add
any up or down the only question is am i
going to be
let's use this color here am i going to
match up exactly am i going to return to
the origin because i do go to
the west direction by a similar looking
amount or am i going to be west or am i
going to be east
i'll be west if i go past the origin and
i'll be east if i don't quite make it
to the origin hopefully now by me sort
of talking this through you've seen
where you're going to end up right am i
going to hit the origin go past it or
just be short
and the answer is knowing that this is
root three
this is root three and this is root
three i've said it already a few times
here root three is about one point seven
right so if you go and punch into your
calculator three times
root three um i mean three times one
point seven is five point one but
there's some extra trailing decimal
places so i think what you'll find is
it's going to be approximately 5.2
this distance here from the origin all
the way to the end
of f3 is about 5.2
which means that if i go um
from the end of f3 and i track
towards oops let's get a straight line
there if i track towards back towards
the origin
am i going to get there after i apply f4
and the answer is
i'm not going to make it because f4
is only 5 units long it's not going to
be
the 5.2 i need to get all the way back
to where i started right can you see
how ultra important it is to have a
really good not just a good diagram a
really good diagram
so that you don't accidentally kind of
stuff yourself up by your scale being
not off i mean it's going to be off a
little bit but you don't want to be so
disastrously off that you can no longer
reason successfully with this diagram
so i haven't even answered the question
yet i just completed my diagram the
question was
what would the motion of the body be is
it going to be in equilibrium and the
answer is no because i don't reach back
to the origin
am i going to be west well i would be
west if i passed the origin but i didn't
i was just short
so what that means is i'm going to be
moving to the east and now because we've
got a good diagram of reason
through it i can say i can zoom in here
and i can even say
it's going to be east and by how much
and the answer is the magnitude will be
oopsie daisy
3 root 3 which was that 5.2 ish number
take away 5 which i guess would be
roughly 0.2
i don't think we even have units for
this like what the magnitude units are
they just say 1 2 4 and 5. so i'm just
going to leave that
as units well they don't even ask this
question
so i hope you can see how i've reasoned
through this and how crucial
the diagram was